i'm interviewing councillor keith hudson
portfolio holder for planning transport
and heritage with watchful district
council about the new local development
framework
council husband why is the council
allocating additional land for housing
the government requires local councils
to ensure that at any given time there
is enough land available to provide for
five years worth of their areas how do
you
we are required to ensure land is
available for 250 new homes to be built
every year
we reached a point where no more sites
were available for housing so we had to
identify additional land
plans that have now been adopted
identify sufficient land up to and
including 2025
a number of people are concerned about
how much new development is being found
why did the council not simply say no to
the government's demand to provide land
for housing
a very good question
let us say we took the position that we
would not accommodate any more homes in
this area
if we produced a plan that said this the
government would not permit us to adopt
it
we know this because others have tried
and failed
if we refused to produce a plan at all
then it would be determined that this
district had a totally permissive
approach to development
as prescribed within the national
planning policy framework
therefore developers would still get
permission to build even if the council
refused
just so long that their proposals were
deliverable and sustainable
there would be no limit to the numbers
and no control whatsoever to the
locations
this has already happened in other
districts where they had no plans in
place
to reiterate with no plan in place
development would still happen but the
council would have little say on how
many new homes where and how development
would take place and what infrastructure
should accompany those developments
by dealing with this thorny issue we
have been able to restrict the release
of our greenbelt land to less than one
percent
kevin only knows what would have
happened if we had left it to chance
i understand that a lot of people are
concerned about the present level of
development
but this is not something that is in the
council's control
i think it is right that the council
make decisions about where development
should go
rather than leaving it effectively to
developers and central governments
these decisions are difficult
but we have had to grasp the network
the alternative burying our heads in the
sand refusing to make the top calls and
leaving it to develop as a central
government would have been a far easier
option for this council
we would not have had to make the
unpopular decisions that we've had to
make
but in my view such an approach would
have been cowardly and would have left
the whole district vulnerable to
unplanned and uncontrolled development
something
so what plan to address these issues
there are two plans that are key to
where and when development takes place
the first is the core strategy
this sets out our overarching approach
to managing new developments of the
district
it covers a whole host of issues but in
relation to housing there are three key
aspects
it requires 30 of all new homes to be
built to be affordable homes
thereby ensuring homes for our local
community local people our housing
waiting list
young people who may need a hand up onto
this housing lender
number two it sets the general locations
where development housing and employment
will be steered to
number three perhaps most importantly by
identifying which areas the housing may
go to it ensures that the vast majority
of the district's greenfield is
protected from development
the core strategy was adopted in 2011
without which we would have seen
developers making applications for
random developments throughout the
district
our second document is the allocations
plan which provides further detail
identifying specific sites within the
general locations as specified in the
core strategy
thus providing detailed policies to
ensure that development is appropriate
to the location and is complete with the
necessary infrastructure
talking of infrastructure
a number of people have expressed
concerns about the impact of
infrastructure from the proposed
development
how is this issue being addressed
infrastructure is a key issue and
another reason why it is best the local
council puts plans in place rather than
simply letting development happen on an
ad hoc basis
by having plans in place we are in a
much stronger position to be able to set
out what infrastructure must accompany
new development
so for example
all new developments will will be
required to undertake a detailed
assessment of their transport impact
right at the beginning at the planning
application stage
they will need to take action to address
these
including improvements to roads
this is the requirement of essex county
council who are the highways authority
and as such the body responsible for
roads and who will oversee this process
there were a number of objections to the
funds how has people's views been taken
into account
community involvement has played a major
role in deciding where and how much
development takes place
for example people may recall that some
years ago the council's original
preferred option was for 1 800 homes
but we listened to residents concerns
and the number was reduced to 550.
the same for sale for qual where the
number of dwellings was half due to the
creep that we received
however i accept that unfortunately we
will never be able to please everyone
but the homes have to go somewhere and
as i said earlier it is much better that
the council make these difficult
decisions
trying to account for residents concerns
wherever possible
rather than for those decisions to be
left to developers and other outsiders
why is the council allocating sites for
tipsy and traveller accommodation
the same government requirements applied
to accommodation for travelers as for
brics and mortar accommodation
in other words we are required to ensure
adequate supply of land is available to
traverse sites and if we do not we will
simply have sites appearing in the
district in an unplanned manner
the fact that we have not previously
allocated enough land for traverse sites
has meant that we have lost appeals in
the past
allocating a site now will put us in a
much stronger position if and when
unauthorized sites appear in the future
the council's vowed intention in this
matter is to ensure that the traveller's
side to be provided in the fair glenn
interchange at the junction of the a127
with the a1245 is municipally owned and
controlled and to this end we have
reached agreements with essex county
council in principle for them to be the
administrators on our behalf
they are the public authority with
considerable experience and have a fine
track record of success in this field
having similar establishments in other
parts of essex
thank you very much councillor for
answering these questions hopefully
they'll be able to provide more of an
insight